[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah french tech c'est l'écosystème des
startups françaises
c'est un label qui est portée donc par
bercy qui est déclinée désormais sur une
centaine de communautés cinquantaine de
communautés en france sur les principaux
pôles d'activité
et puis une cinquantaine de communauté à
l'étranger castaic paris-saclay on va
porter des événements comme comme
l'événement de ce soir on a l'intention
d'en organiser trois par an qui seront
l'occasion pour les start up de notre
écosystème de se rencontrer d'échanger
toujours dans une dans un contexte de
convivialité l'organisation sid
événements thématiques qui seraient pas
couverts et d'ateliers par exemple on va
faire le lien aussi avec les grands
groupes du territoire être le relais
auprès des pouvoirs publics et favoriser
en fait les connexions avec les offres
qui sont proposés à l'échelle nationale
comme les offres de dpi de business
france sur le financement et
l'accompagnement à l'export essayer de
répondre aux problématiques avec le
facilitateur en essayant de mobiliser le
réseau des startups en général quand on
est face à une difficulté on a
probablement d'autres entrepreneurs qui
ont vécu la même chose et en facilitant
les échanges je pense qu'on pourrait
être plus rapide et plus efficace
ce soir c'était le deuxième événement
organisé par l'afrique paris saclay on
avait l'occasion de 4 juillet de faire
une soirée de lancement qui avait
rassemblé de nombreuses startups du
territoire et aujourd'hui c'est un
nouveau rendez vous
donc le rendez vous de l'automne à
même
une configuration l'occasion de
rencontrer des interlocuteurs variés
d'avoir des speakers que nous ont fait
le plaisir nous rejoindre et puis
maintenant un moment de convivialité un
buffet quelques bières des jeux en
réalité virtuelle de la pétanque du ping
pong manière à favoriser les échanges et
est vraiment structuré animé cette
communauté de start up
[Musique]